hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q and a segment
number 122
that's right
i inadvertently said something terrible
at the end of the last live stream
i said that we had put our cat to sleep
yes and you caught me and you didn't say
anything but like he's sitting right
here he's sitting right here and he is
he's very sweepy see there he is there
he is
it's just fine i did not mean to say it
that way i didn't even know it that i'd
set it that way there we go let me get a
little fairfax action for the camera
all right
um
just jump right in
from the discord
this week we have this question
many adaptations seem like they would be
maladaptive at first
for instance a partial limb growing on a
fish-like creature seems like it would
just interfere with swimming and not
confirm the benefits that we'll
eventually be selected for how do you
explain this
um yeah how do you explain this well
the real question
depends what we're talking about if
we're talking about let's say
fish
fishy fish as we call them since
tetrapods are fish
um but fishy fish that is to say fish
that look like fish
the kind of fish that are evoked when
you say the word fish
um
i'm just trying to be very very clear
about what i mean by fish
said the fish failing to the other fish
in front of the third fish
totally eat some fish right now yeah we
could go for some fish but
the the point is you don't have
limbs
uh in the sense of walking limbs on
the fish that are the ancestors of the
limbed
tetrapods you have lobes that have a
purpose in
the fishy fishes equal ecology which we
now know so let's let's tell the story
yeah yeah right so i mean
some some of these what can you bring up
acetela camp
you could say what you're doing you want
me to dive right now no no no no no no
no no not an actual celia campbell
because i just i don't even i don't have
a certified gonna have to go to the
indian ocean not in indonesia exactly
jesus christ the things you ask of me um
coelacanth
yeah coelacanth with a c man my um
all right and things are not working i
was i was going to explain something
you've got me searching on things here
well i don't i this is not what i want
to be doing
should i let you explain there you go um
i don't know that this is not that
interesting though um there are better
fish to be to be showing but um okay
there's a
rogue
thing there okay
zoom in on this oh my god
hey there we go
i don't know which this is where it is i
don't know anything about it but it's
that's definitely a coelacanth yep it's
not the best picture i've ever seen but
it's a coelacanth um
okay this particular story is very well
understood and there's still pieces that
are disputed but it's so well understood
and it's so beautiful
that this will be
we're not going to tell the whole story
here we'll tell some of it
but it's it's a relatively easy one
there are
lots for which we can
we can either we actually either have
the molecular or paleontological
or physiological or anatomical evidence
or we can absolutely put together
the theoretical argument for what the
various stages might have been good for
there are also a lot of cases where we
won't necessarily be able to do that but
that doesn't put the lie to the story
okay so the fact is with um
with
basil tetrapods
which are that branch of fish so we have
i mean how far back even do we go we got
osteoactivities we've got the bony os
icky's fish we got the ostiac these
which include everything that you can
think of that's called a fish
except for
sharks
um skates and rays
um and then they're roughly they're
completely divided into the the rayfin
fishes and the lobeton fishes and if
you've ever eaten fish or caught fish or
talked to fish or thought about fish
much looked at fish in a fish tank
and looked carefully at their at their
fins um you will see indeed lots and
lots and lots of very fine thin bone
bony rays okay um that is
in contrast to a different branch of the
osteothesis of the bony fish
that started to have a reduction in
those rays into fewer and fewer elements
like
8 10
and then they became thicker and then
those
those fins became more like lobes they
became sort of fleshy they became there
was there was more um soft tissue on
them rather than the the fins of rayfin
fish are really just those rays and and
skin there's there's not a lot else
going on there um so the lobe fins
seem to be useful
for walking around in shallow water
this is not exactly how i would
describe the story
first of all the coelacanth which is
was thought to be a
extinct lineage was rediscovered alive
which allowed us to it was understood to
be related to basal tetrapods because it
had these
limb like projections where rayfin fish
have the rays because it was discovered
alive and there are now i think three
species that have been found separately
this
so-called living fossil allows us to
understand what those lobes were doing
and it isn't inherently shallow water
the point is the ecology of these fish
involved them walking on the sea floor
and
yeah but coelacanths aren't basil within
the lofan fish right but nonetheless
from the point of view of why would a
fully aquatic fish have limb-like
projections the point is there's
something in its ecology that causes
those things to pay on that we can agree
um so i was gonna go back and find the
phylogenetic trees um from my early
tetrapod lectures and i'm not i i can't
search and try to have this conversation
at the same time
um but i mean really if you're
interested in this question your inner
fish by neil shubin is is the go-to book
um the coelacanth is a later but still
not very um
not very highly derived uh lobe-finned
fish that still lives in the water there
are also lungfish um and then most of
the lobe fin fish have emerged from the
water and those um those those things
which were reduced in number from the
rays uh into fewer became fewer and
fewer and we had early amphibians and
then of course the diversity of
tetrapods
but it seems the the evidence for the
first emergence
on the land of the tetrapods was in
these very shallow like i can't remember
if it was the tethosc but you know
something's comparable some very
probably not because that's probably too
late i'm not sure i have my timing right
but something very very shallow um with
a lot of opportunity sort of right at
the edge like right at the edge between
land and water where being able to have
a little bit of musculature on your fins
and basically pull yourself a little bit
out uh would have allowed for um
and
for things that were previously
completely restricted to water to take
advantage of some of the life that was
now teeming on land because this was um
an era in which there were a lot of
insects coming to be around yeah i would
describe it as a
gentle slope on the adaptive landscape
the same i thought you were going to
we might we'll see we'll see where this
goes but
um but the basic point is we describe
evolutionarily that innovations are like
on little foothills of peaks that get
climbed by selection which keeps
refining things and the basic point that
heather is making which is if you are a
aquatic fish
and there is stuff to eat at the meander
line let's say where the water has
washed things in and out
insects have died and accumulated maybe
they're
you know eating seaweed or something
like that as we've all seen at the shore
and the ability to get a little bit
further
out of the water than your competitors
avails you of a whole lot of food so
it's a gentle slope that then easily
gets climbed the more limy you are the
more effective you are at getting
further and further away from the water
of course and it allows for um
fluctuations in water level that will
happen in a very vast shallow area that
is um that is uh responsive to tides as
such areas would be such that if you
have some musculature in your fins which
can be accommodated by having those
fewer bony elements as opposed to those
many elements
then you might be able to survive a
drying event and get to a next area over
as opposed to just being a fish out of
wire right so what we've effectively
done is we've said in the initial
ancestor there will be there's not going
to be appendages that don't pay right
actually if you look into our book we
talk about the
test for adaptation in there and the
basic point is those limbs or limb like
projections
are made of stuff
they have a complexity to them they're a
vulnerability the only reason that an
animal would have them is because it's
paying it
it's paying back if you eliminate the
benefit it will have them temporarily
you'll have a vestigial condition but it
will be quickly
eliminated by selection because there's
no reason to pay that cost
but once you've got them like you're a
coelacanth-like creature
that uses those limbs to maneuver on the
sea floor then the point is you're
actually in a good position to take
advantage of the situation that heather
points out where there's an ecological
opportunity that those that rayfin fish
can't uh access
and so anyway somewhere in there is
buried the answer to the question that
you were asking
yes indeed um so i did find
i used to be so good with um
powerpoint and i've forgotten uh wow
that see that did exactly the wrong
thing i just wanted to show one
slide here
um but i can't
i want the normal view i want a good
view
okay there we go so
you can't see anything
that's not the case but now it's opened
up illustrator for no good reason so um
perhaps it's time to move on my computer
now this this should be displaying to
you guys you really can't see that
but you but
all right i think we should move on okay
solve this later
i am trying
there we go
three parts
that did not quite come in in
the right or here we go they're numbered
it begins within this respect so it
seems like it's a continuation but i
think this is the first the first thing
in this respect the total moral collapse
of respectable society during the hitler
regime may teach us that under such
circumstances those who cherish values
and hold fast to moral norms and
standards are not reliable
we now know that moral norms and
standards can be changed overnight
and that all that then will be left is
the mere habit of holding fast to
something
much more reliable will be the doubters
and skeptics not because skepticism is
good or doubting wholesome but because
they are used to examine things and to
make up their own minds
best of all will be those who know only
one thing for certain that whatever else
happens as long as we live we shall have
to live together with ourselves
now they've gotten to the end i see that
this is a hannah arant quotation from
responsibility and judgment page 45.
amazing yeah there's a lot a lot of
wisdom in there that's that's remarkable
but i would say
a rent is so
good she may indeed cover this i don't
mean to correct her but
there are two
fail-safes
against different failure modes one of
them is the obligate skeptic who will
spot nonsense as it
begins to invade and at the moment this
is the era of such people because the
nonsense is so universal and has such
powerful tools that accompany it you
didn't just call the obligate skeptic of
failure mode no the obligate skeptic is
an answer to a failure model okay right
to slavish devotion to something that
drives you over a cliff
um
but there's the other thing too right
the
um
woke failure mode in which everything
that we once understood is suddenly
null and void in favor of some new fad
is a problem too and the idea that you
know
conservatives are
adhering to definitions of
man woman
rules of mathematics that do cause two
plus two to equal four an agreement that
we had until five minutes ago that
pedophilia was bad right
those things are a matter of hey wait a
minute i i don't care that you're
skeptical of math you don't get to do
that right right um so anyway two
failure modes one is a kind of absurd
skepticism that wrecks all kinds of
structure that uh works
and the other uh is devotion to
uh tradition that causes you to to
fail out of obligation i think i think
you've done this more cleanly um and you
used to actually start out some of your
classes by asking students to define
three terms
cynicism skepticism and faith yeah and
um i would i would argue that as i
thought you were beginning to talk about
but then at the end i i grew confused
again um that you are allowing that
utter faith and utter cynicism that is
complete fealty to either that which has
come before or that which the
authorities say
or complete rejection of that which has
come before or that which authorities
say simply because it's authority's
saying it are both failure modes but
skepticism being open to what is
possible and uh not assuming that
something is right just because you um
think the source is cool um is is the
right way through right a
proper
a well-tuned amount of skepticism rather
than skepticism is the answer right
because skepticism is the answer can
become sophistry right where you're just
throwing rocks absolutely at everything
no matter how secure it is and so yes i
agree that it's an admixture question
and you know this this goes to a lot of
places this goes to also uh the thing i
always say about it's not that the
answer is liberal or conservative the
dynamism comes from the tension between
those two things and conservatives are
very good at avoiding you from making
new mistakes and liberals are very good
at figuring out what problems might be
worth solving and that either one of
these alone is a disaster
um
so anyway yes and you know who deals
with this pretty well
you and me in our book
um yeah we talk about chesterton's fence
and the precautionary principle which
are really
uh
the two hazards yep
very much so
okay next question
how do we fix climate science
and stop it from publishing impossible
garbage which ignores statistics
measurement uncertainties and the
sparseness and incompleteness of the
data sets
you know the problem is i don't know how
you fix any of this without fixing the
root problem which is that perverse
incentives
the systems that are supposed to be how
do you fix health science it's the same
question and economics and
and everything and everything and so the
point is look i think it is fair to say
you and i do not want responsibility for
having been ignored in trying to point
out that these systems were being pushed
in a direction that they were destined
to fail yeah and that you means things
that we were talking about long before
we had a pla you know long before many
people were listening to it right we
were talking about numbers of people
about uh this problem and the answer is
what do we do
um yep that's a doozy it's not obvious
that we have a good way out and to the
extent that there is a good way out it's
going to be
a couple of generations before it's
fixed because what you've done is you've
lobotomized your entire intellectual
class and so who you know even to the
extent that the answer is you start
having smart people teach the youngans
things that are actually true and useful
right who are those people where are you
going to find them right and i mean
that's part of
maybe i didn't know it at the time but
that's part of why i've been thinking
about phonology
which i brought up in the first hour two
hours almost that we did um which is
that you know this is something this is
low-tech this has been being done
for for
decades into centuries um it is
something that you can use to you know
track change in your own backyard
uh and you know change and or
consistency uh it gets you in the habit
of keeping track of things which has
utility that um you know habits of
habits of of
note taking can become habits of mind
can become useful in all sorts of ways
that you may not understand
um but one of the things that i
mentioned in the first hour was that
phenological records of you know taken
by amateurs taken by you know people who
were just enthusiastic about seeing when
the first bluebird showed up
um
are useful now in tracking the you know
the advance in many places
of or the advance or the retreat of the
timing of when the frogs start calling
the birds start arriving the flowers
start um
blooming right now this is this is
these actually represent data sets that
you can go back into and ask questions
of with hypotheses that you generate
later but without awareness of what's in
the data and therefore you can test
those hypotheses by going back and
looking at those data sets that
pre-existed you right it's actually
um surely this is
studied and explored somewhere but
uh our system of taxonomy
right is linnaean yes linnaeus was pre
darwin right so you had a guy who was
operating in a world in which special
creation was more or less the presumed
explanation for all of these creatures
and
correctly and very ingeniously noting
that the design of these creatures
caused you to group them in logical ways
and so the point is he didn't have the
tool to understand the darwinian
explanation of the relationship of these
things but he still saw categories and
we still use his mechanism because the
point is when you do finally understand
what caused these things to be you know
degrees of similar to each other the
point is oh well then all of that
similarity that you noted that had a
different cause than you understood is
still relevant yeah the only part sorry
but the only you know the only part
really that we've completely rejected
um from the lenaen naming system is the
idea that there is like whatever it is
seven you know it's like there's there
are species and there are genera and
there are families and there are
you know yeah on and on like because you
know there's not there's not seven
nested sets for every organism you know
there there are many many many and uh as
as i was
once advised by the great arnold
cloughey we issue categorical ranks we
eschew categorical rank and by we he
meant the three of us and a few other of
his friends but
um yeah categorical rank being family
order class et cetera right but this is
actually one of these places where i
find almost no biologist who didn't go
through
the phytogenetic systematics and the
philosophical underpinnings of it
understand a what the lesson here is you
wish categorical rank are you saying you
know that uh
the you know that the family and the
genus of this organism are
not meaningful no no they're clades
right but they're not in you you could
you could say you know actually this
genus is really a family and you don't
change anything about the biology and
switching the level right that it's at
nor are there seven um this is actually
something i explore in this essay i just
posted on natural selections oh yeah the
taxonomy what is what is the reason for
names
right and you know names are about ease
of communication and
for that we would want stability of
names we would want the field book you
know the that we pick up today to be the
same names as from 20 years ago but
names are also about representing
reality representing historical truth
and so as our understanding of history
changes we expect the names themselves
to change as well and that makes
communication harder so we have two very
different reasons to have names for
things but we only have the one set of
names
right
but
very few biologists understand that it
isn't fair to compare the number of
species in one family to the number of
species in another family even though
the two families may be real and the
species diagnosed may be real but it's a
meaningless comparison it's a
meaningless comparison and yet you see
them done in you know scientific
publications and so anyway the point is
even most biologists have not caught up
to the idea that categorical rank is one
of the things that we're over yeah
almost nobody's over it even though they
absolutely should be and it would make
their science better
um
but
nonetheless
we are in a process in which
some and it's actually it's a good match
for what we were discussing uh in terms
of how to think versus what to think
right the how to think doesn't isn't
thrown a monkey wrench because the
particulars are turn out not to be right
right because the point is you can
reapply them
and this is a place where um
you know we have an obvious upgrade that
just hasn't made it to
to most biologists you know for most of
them it's irrelevant right if you're
working on
uh c elegans right you're not dealing
with phylogeny you're dealing with a
creature that's lodged one place in the
phylogeny right and you're not comparing
it really no but um many ecologists are
actually
engaging with phylogeny without knowing
so and and doing so crudely and uh
therefore making errors yeah and the
same is true for conservation biology
that's not generally going to be um you
know a problem for climate science but
it's a different it's a different set of
it's a different set of issues
this person begins by stating his name
so i think he wants me to share it
um
my name is kevin collins 15-year flight
paramedic living in tri-cities
washington would you please have on
james lindsay to discuss the unraveling
of schools into queer theory and crt and
how marxism
um
is spreading throughout the country
please please please
uh i see no reason not to have him on it
he was certainly on
the
[Music]
uh unity 2020 a couple times right you
had them on but yeah so yeah
it's possible i haven't had them on
darkhorse i think that's probably i
think it's right yeah um anyway yeah
yeah
hey james what do you think
we also have other ways of reaching him
yes yes
um
hello from toronto canada my question is
regarding covet transmission is it
possible for the outside of a mask that
has filtered out virus to make
accidental contact with one's chin and
with the mask on you breathe in covet
yes
um very unlikely in covid's case but
possible but but you ask if it's
possible and
yeah you've violated no
known rules of the universe
in that scenario yeah
i'd be so grateful to hear how you would
handle your 13 year old child telling
you they are the wrong sex
i'm afraid to make things worse
it depends a lot on um
on who they are and what your
relationship with them is and probably
where you are like what what cultural
part of the
country or world uh you are in and
um not just who they are now but what
their what their history has been um and
what your history with them has been uh
it also matters what sex they actually
are to some degree um
because uh a girl who's coming to you
a daughter who's coming to you telling
you that they're they're born the wrong
sex they're actually a boy
is more likely
to be succumbing to a social situation
than a boy who is coming to you saying
the same thing a boy who is coming to
you saying the same thing is still very
unlikely to be
actually trans and
if it comes on all of a sudden
that's a good indicator that it's
that it's a social fiction
um
if you have talked
if you have talked to them before about
um
anything biological or natural or
scientific this will be somewhat easier
i think
um
i'm just i'm trying to think
it's it's hard
trying to think of what
we would have said had it come to
our
had this come from
one of our children or someone whom we
knew well
i think
a you need to recognize that you've been
robbed of
useful tools that a civilization who has
become confused about this
a civilization that has become confused
about this has undermined
your parental authority and i think this
is part of you know people are
there is
lots of talk of grooming and lots of
talk about the abuse of that
term but there is something strange
about society suddenly insisting that it
has the right to tell your children all
kinds of things about sex sexuality
gender etc and
so a
you're not failing because you don't
know what to say you've been put in an
impossible situation
were it me i would you therefore want to
know what is in your child's head newly
from other sources besides you yeah yeah
i think the thing that i would say and
again i'm not telling you that this is
sufficient
right maybe nothing is but
i think the thing that i would say is
you know there is a long history of
people
who have reached that conclusion
and some of them
turn out to feel that way over the long
term but there is also a very long
history of people
having that sense
and it going away and them being glad
that they did not act on it right the
number of people for whom dysphoria
resolves is very high and so
i think the point that the point that
you want to drive home to your child is
the last thing you want to do is take
this thing that you feel very strongly
at this moment and make permanent
decisions based on it because most of
the people who might have done that are
glad they didn't because it simply
resolves
maybe again depending on your
relationship with your child and who you
both are and
what other family you have and
everything
um this is this this feels
very much like a at least a part of a
good response um
it's it's hard for children to
understand time and it's hard for
children to understand permanence
but
um
i'm thinking about that dr seuss book oh
the places you'll go
which is about
how much opportunity there is everything
is ahead of you like you you open one
door
and maybe you shut it behind you but
look at how many more doors are ahead of
you and what you don't want to be doing
when you're young
is
closing doors permanently that you don't
have to
right and
we make lots of choices and they they
open and close doors variously but
presumably at 13 your child has been
through phases
and probably had
some activities that they enjoyed for a
while and no longer do
or you know
things things like that and
if you were to say to them when you were
really into rocks
and
you could have made a decision then
um to become a geologist for sure
maybe this is maybe this is the wrong
example right but um
you probably would have wanted to do so
then and yeah you're older now and you
feel like you know everything now but no
one ever knows everything about what it
is that they're going to want to do and
one of the things for instance that
people want to do later that many people
don't think they want to do when they're
young
is have families of their own
and
if
you
were to act on believing that you are
born the wrong sex
there's a very good chance that one of
the many many doors that would shut for
you is being able to have a family of
your own someday
um i say that stepping out now of trying
to act as a parent who i've never met
talking to a child who i've never met
um
i never i don't know if that would have
landed for me
um i was a tomboy i never thought i was
a boy but i was
gender non-conforming on so many
different levels
and it wasn't because of that
um that i also just didn't think about
having kids i didn't think about
marriage i you know have the love of my
life who i found early and that's
amazing but i didn't for me i didn't
have the princess fantasies the wedding
fantasies the marriage fantasies the
family i didn't have any of it oh you
didn't i really didn't and
um
the point that i got pregnant was a
surprise to both of us
um hey zac
but um
but we had but but we had also long
already talked about we will want to
have kids but you know by my late 20s
yeah i think we i think we do i think
you know we we do want to have that but
that was a long time after 13. yeah at
13
um you say to a kid you know what if
what if you want to have a family one
day maybe that doesn't land at all maybe
it does for some kids it will there are
a lot of girls in particular who are
really thinking very much of that as
part of their identity at that point
but you you know you know you and you
know your child
and you will know what kinds of things
matter to them and what they are sure
they care about so deeply and probably
they won't care about in five years just
because that's how things go
and um are certain of now and probably
won't be certain of in five years things
like this because that's the way things
go
um and what things won't land as much
but there there are likely to be many
many ways in
around the sort of theme of
i want to see you expanding your
possibilities i want to see you be
everything i as your parent want to see
everything you could possibly be and
have as many options as possible and
this may feel like an important real
thing right now but it will shut down
your options and it will close doors for
you and you will have a very hard time
escaping from a decision that you want
to make or a series of decisions that
you want to make right now
so i have another another thought i
think this is an important topic it's
worth worth the time
when you are young
you are often under the mistaken
impression
that you are involved in the and this is
part of the problem with not having
rights of passage is that you believe
that you are
sort of in the adult world already and
you know especially you're on social
media in the same place the adults are
battling stuff out yeah and the point is
you may feel
that
you have no idea how to do how to become
relevant how to do something important
that will matter over your life and i
think you know we all
wondered about that as as young people
and you don't realize that in fact it
would be very very unlikely as a
teenager to do anything that would be
significant in term you know you could
set yourself on a path but it's very
hard to produce anything as a teenager
that ends up mattering and in fact i
used to say this to our college students
too
which is you are not in college to
produce stuff the chances that you will
write something in college that will
matter in the world is pretty low
the chances that you will upgrade your
mind so that you are capable of writing
things that matter is potentially high
it's at least much higher and so that's
the thing you should be building the
tool that's what you're doing and the
things that you're producing our
practice right
but if we don't have rights of passage
and so you sort of feel like oh my god
the adult world is full of stuff that
matters and
some of my peers are doing things that
certainly seem significant people are
paying attention and people are paying
attention the point is what could you do
right now that would suddenly make you
relevant
and the answer is this is something you
can do to make yourself relative
relevant instantly you will become the
focus of a debate over what's right and
whether self-determination this that and
the other and it's fiction right you're
being lured into adult consequence
levels yeah like severe adult
consequence levels yeah right it's not
like
becoming addicted to a drug which you
can then become unaddicted to like
that's a that's an adult thing and it's
very very serious but obviously it's not
the same level of serious as i would
like to decide today as a 13 year old
that i don't want a family right that's
potentially irreversible and so
somehow i think what we need to do is
convey
to our kids that they are not
in the place where they need to be
worried that they are falling behind the
relevant people they're not supposed to
be
attaining relevance yet and
that that pressure is dangerous
yeah
it is very dangerous and so somehow
trying to help your child find their
joy
and you know it's too young for them to
be expected to know their passion they
may have lots of ideas and they may have
no ideas about what it is they think
they're interested in and both things
are fine
but they can find joy you can find joy
at any age and i think
in middle school in modern weird middle
school there's not a lot of joy in
general
but i think especially
post covid it's not post coven
right now
with the last two years behind us there
is so much less joy than there was
and um
grabbing attention has replaced
experiencing joy as
a primary motivator i think and if you
can help your child find
find joy then
then that may well help
it disturbs me
this is just a comment it disturbs me
when someone openly lies
biden's dementia hunter's laptop they
stare me in the face their eyes tell me
they can see i know they're lying but
they lie anyway
yeah i think this is why the term
gaslighting which is frankly not
perfectly it's not precise for most of
what people use it for but there are
very
few things
that properly connote the way somebody
shifts
the burden that comes from seeing
reality onto the person seeing reality
and so the person who will lie to your
face and basically leave you in a bind
you know do you really want to be
accusing an old man of having
dementia well no nobody does the fact is
this is freaking inhumane that anybody
put him in the situation
in which we in the public have to say we
are entitled to a non-demented president
right that's not a nice thing to say i
do as much as i think that
biden
is a
corrupt political
operative a hack
right i don't want to be saying about an
old man that i think he's demented i
want to be able
to have the polite fiction that he's as
sharp as he ever was
and not to have to do with it but
you know you put somebody like that in a
position of power we have to talk about
it so anyway somebody is using the rules
of polite society against us
where we become mean jerks for pointing
out that our president has dementia
and
you're just damned if you do damned if
you don't and the person who lies to
your face
knows that you can see they're lying and
is putting is basically trusting that
the complexity of calling them out is so
great that you won't do it right that
person that's true yeah they have
availed themselves of an illegal toolkit
and i agree it is
particularly galling and so you know the
problem is we have very few things that
really evoke it and you know gaslight
this movie that i think most of us have
never seen
um
gets there because the idea is
your powers of perception are going to
be used against you they're going to get
gamed
and you will not know which way is up
and
we all face
analogs of that too frequently now
how to get mrs dorothy asks
how to get rid of bats that leave guano
right by our front door
um
put a plant right where they leave it
and enjoy your baths and the
your plant will flourish because of all
of that guano not if you're you
none of you have a protected
opening that is therefore also protected
from the sun and
it never gets any light at all it will
be
rich in nitrogen and phosphorus i
imagine guano is but rather poor in
sugars
yes
agreed not every
entryway is perfectly suited to
utilizing i mean most aren't right
frankly because the guano com like falls
down the wall and like right i mean
we've we had a bat house we we asked for
it we had a bat house on our house in
olympia
um and there was
boy one year we counted them coming out
a little bad house
it was it was about a foot wide by a
foot and a half tall when it happened
no it wasn't i put it up
i didn't know how big it was well it
wasn't it wasn't close to square it was
much it was rectangular yeah um anyway
zach and i both remember it being
anyway in any case it wasn't this big it
was not deep it was not deep at all it
was it looked like it was deep enough to
hold one bat deep
and i would have said
eight or ten i would have said well
maybe i would have set about but you i
don't know like that wide and it would
have been wise to you to say about what
i'm saying because that's the size it
was
anyway it wasn't
where were we
um
so one night
we were lying on the deck as they were
about to emerge to watch them approach
not underneath the thing because right
it would be wrong not with our mouths
open
um and
did we count 77 damn bats come out 76 or
77 yeah it was amazing it was
unbelievable and previously in my
previous nights we had like 30 were like
how did they fit 30 bats in there and
then just kept coming this one night
wow and it wasn't like we had good tight
cedar shingle siding they weren't under
the siding it was in the house ken you
could see them coming out of the house
crazy so anyway we asked for it and
there was guano and we and i did put a
couple of plants this is on the deck so
this and it did it was um
west facing um so it got nice sun
went through the trees uh but
most planters are round and so you know
i caught a certain amount of the guano
and every week or two i'd have to go in
and like hose out the deck so the deck
didn't rot from bat guano because we put
tiny little bat house up above
um all of which is not an answer like
this this is a this is an issue and if
you know if you know that you don't
really want to be the kind of person who
kills off bats but you also really don't
like the guanoba
um i don't have an answer
let's put it this way you could make the
spot that the animal is it one animal
it's probably one animal that hangs
there sometimes
um
you could make the spot
inhospitable right you could put up a
slippery piece of plastic or something
and uh just make it so that the animal
will learn to go somewhere else
uh you could try don't say bats
that's yeah well it depends if you've
got a space and they're getting into
something then the answer if they're
getting into something you don't want
them doing that you've got to close off
the space yeah
yeah
it can't be good for the siding can't no
um
trade-offs in all things um look
i don't know how many bats you got you
might figure that out
if you've got a hole in your building
you could seal the hole do it when the
bats are out um
this should be obvious yeah you would
think but um
given the uh
let's put it this way a person is liable
to do this during the day right true
true true true
that's the wrong moment yeah you've run
into a certain amount of uh person
thinking on bat problems and it is
exactly often is a photo period issue
let's put it to you this way personally
if i'm awake they must be awake wrong
they're sleeping they're in there now
person thinking on bat problems is not
much better than bad thinking on
personal problems which is not good well
we actually don't know how good it is on
the other hand we've had none of our
problems solved by bats as far as we
know right they just even if maybe well
occasionally they take out some of the
mosquitoes that might otherwise bite you
indeed
it's not
the thing that i've heard i've never
deployed this myself it's usually more
an attic thing
is hanging strips of
aluminum foil
which i the the idea is that it
interferes with echolocation my guess is
it's highly reflective really freaking
annoying if you're echolocated
vibrating
you know it's like every time you spoke
somebody broke out
right it's that kind of thing so anyway
i don't know how well it works like we
will find someone else's house thank you
very much
someone who
doesn't own aluminum
you try that let us know what happens i
think that ended up being a you know
a b answer oh yeah
it was a great okay almost a b-plus
answer i thought
okay excellent um
all right let's see
uh
appreciated your answer last week on
synthetics versus organics but can you
think of any examples specifically
within food cleaning and medicine
also best books on organic living
i will come up with nothing best books
on organic living off the top of my head
i just i just won't be able to come up
with any
boy i thought that we came up with some
cleaning stuff like i i think i
mentioned uh
bleach
but maybe maybe the idea is like you
want really high tech well okay i don't
actually like it very much like i have
my qualms about it but you like oxiclean
oxiclean well so oxyclean is a hydrogen
peroxide generator and basically
hydrogen peroxide is pretty good but
it's also
you know
yes it's synthetically produced but it's
still pretty low-tech it's simple it's
molecularly simple it's a molecule that
exists as is bleach molecularly simple
common molecule yeah um bleach
less so
less simple
less like encountered hydrogen peroxide
encounter and so the safety of it is
better
pretty good in fact yeah but something
an agent whose power rests on you know
the single metric of where it falls on
the ph scale is still pretty simple
right so i mean that's a simple
mechanism of action but then again you
know cyanide is
pretty freaking simple and it's
mechanism of action that's pretty
freaking simple and it's
it's not good for you
yeah i know i didn't
i i wasn't saying simple is good i don't
make that mistake no i was saying it's
not high tech
yeah i mean it isn't um
i am a huge fan of isopropyl alcohol um
because it's readily available
and i guess so i was thinking oh it's
alcohol it doesn't count at all but i
guess isopropyl
um
i mean but but why is isopropyl better
than
pouring the stuff you made in your still
oh i don't think it is on the counter
yeah it's not it's just it's just more
precious like you can buy isopropyl
cheap probably yeah isopropyl you can
get cheaply if you try to buy industrial
ethanol it comes with
bitterness
to keep people from abusing it
so does that matter from a cleaning
perspective
potentially potentially in other words
if you're you know if i use a spray
bottle of isopropyl
right yeah on account actually on a
toilet
yeah maybe
right yeah um but the bitter and if you
spray it into the air you know is it
gonna irritate your eyes okay
so anyway i like isopropyl we could have
debate you know it's also a
simple molecule
i don't know how frequently one
encounters isopropyl but i guess it's
not zero
um in nature
um but
examples in food
i mean this is tough yeah really not i
mean there's stuff that humans have done
that seems
so improbable that it's really close to
impossible like how we ended up
with vanilla with chocolate with coffee
like each of those three species has
just when you see the plant growing as
as we have and you run into it in the
wild we've run into vanilla in
cultivation but growing but the other
two in the wild um boys they're just
it's really hard to imagine the number
of steps that got to
you know a chocolate bar a cup of coffee
um and it just had to be an incredible
amount of of um
trial and error but that's still human
ingenuities at a pre-industrial
revolution right so
you know i remember i remember
when would it have been
10 or 15 years ago when the molecular
gastronomy craze happened
and i was like man is that a disaster
what what what garbage like why would
you do that to food because you can well
it doesn't mean that you should yeah
right
uh so
well but let's see
examples i'm coming up with are again
pre-industrial like grafting so that you
can have
um apple trees
um
that that breed that they don't breed
that they grow true
um
yeah i mean and you know but
i think grafting wait that's not the way
i will treat it different crafting
bananas
bananas and grafting those those
yeah because the bananas are sterile yes
um
i don't think grafting it counts right
exactly that's that's what i said um
banana is actually pretty good in terms
of bananas are artificial
but we have to explain that yeah and
it's not that we can't tell the other
story too so the the thing is a banana
is a triploid sterile
a true wild banana triploid meaning i
don't know how far back we go but so
we're we're diploid we have two copies
of each of our chromosomes um our sex
cells are haploid you know egg egg has
only 23 chromosomes whereas all the rest
of your cells in your body agrosperm
have 46 triploid means you have three
copies and triploid doesn't um divide
evenly by two and so doesn't tend to
engage a triplet organism doesn't do
sexually production very effectively
yeah this is why
the banana you buy at the supermarket
doesn't have seeds
um it's a sterile critter
and so it has to be grown with this
fancy technology which has left it
incredibly vulnerable to uh yup
pandemics of fungus is my understanding
yeah and in fact the great banana the
one that
the great the great banana is the
magician from the mid-20th century it's
like the great pumpkin but less of a
cartoon the great banana uh that was the
one on which the banana industry uh
reached the world
uh actually became non-viable and i
don't know if it's extinct or
nearly so
but we now get a lesser banana that was
bypassed as a strain initially because
it has an unpleasant taste note in it
which we all now look past
um and it is now threat i don't know
this part
rob dunn has done a really good
exploration not when was the story told
but when
when did we start eating a different
banana
mid 20th century so most of most of us
alive never tasted the old banana i
think that's right okay i think that's
right because i feel like
that's
interesting if we experienced a change
in the banana we're eating and didn't
notice because you know when you go when
you go to the tropics
i don't eat bananas up here i'm not
interested in them they don't taste good
to me they go to the tropics like oh
those bananas are good yeah they are
better they don't have to travel
whatever they're called
um but little bananas yeah i have
another name i've forgotten it but
anyway um
so our modern strain is also
uh apparently
succumbing to a pathogenic fungus i
think and the point is that would be
expected because
the non-sexual reproduction of these
bananas does make them more consistent
but it means they're vulnerable because
they don't have the kind of variation in
which some variants would be resistant
etc and so um do i recommend
you know the banana
as a evidence of a synthetic that is
useful a i don't know that it quite
meets the definition because it's a
triploid
um but b i don't know that i net
recommend it maybe we'd be better off
with bananas that had seeds and
you didn't go extinct as a result of
pathogens right so i i think your
question is a really good one and i
would say
i think we've done
a very good job at coming up with
good synthetics right up to the border
of food and i'm going to be surprised if
we come up with a good compelling
example of a synthetic food that's
actually recommendable not only as
tasty but a good idea for you to eat
well there's red bull
yeah red bull don't get me started i
know there are lots of champions of red
bull out there
none of them yeah
the other thing on the list is medicine
and
i mean that's a whole that's
most most of our modern medicines
have been at least purified and titrated
in the lab so that you know the dosage
you're getting you know it's pure you're
supposed to know it's pure and you're
supposed to know exactly the amount
you're getting so that you can
um so that it so that a doctor can
prescribe for instance a particular dose
and and then you can you can take that
particular dose
um
no this is this is a slam dunk there are
there are medicines and let me give you
an example it's not people medicine but
it's proof of concept okay
uh our
first epic tabby
uh
was a very cool cat named abercrombie
who uh he was exactly he yeah he had
thumbs he had a great winning
personality he had he was he had dog
characteristics he was a smart
innovative cat
drove us crazy every so often by going
on walkabout and
worrying us but anyway when he conned
this is when we were living in ann arbor
he uh he managed to convince an old lady
across the pond from us that uh he was
homeless and so she would feed him
sometimes oh yeah no he took advantage
of the same stuff that telemarketers do
but i mean he was a more honest cat than
that but um
but anyway
incidentally you got fairfax to sit up
and just reveal himself briefly yeah
he's not worried no
um anyway
abercrombie was a great animal he did
have
a propensity
to
he was the cat around which the nine
lives thing was built he had he
had a
tumor that nearly killed him that when
they removed it they discovered it
wasn't a tumor it was a fungus that was
closing off his uh
his esophagus anyway it apparently got
written up in a medical journal
i don't know he got bitten by something
and came back with a head swollen up
like a small grapefruit
anyway one of the things he got was
actually a kind of a common one
which is he got a thyroid tumor
and the thyroid tumor causes cats
apparently yeah causes a metabolic
disorder in which the cat the thermostat
gets turned way up it starts burning a
ton of calories he became incredibly
hungry and emaciated and it was like oh
god this is a cat on the way out
and this is where we discovered one of
the treatments
not legal everywhere at the time i don't
know where what its status is now
but
the
treatment was
radioactive iodine
and
the idea was the thyroid all of our
thyroids including human thyroid take up
iodine which is why when there's a
nuclear accident you're supposed to take
non-radioactive iodine so your thyroid
gets filled up and the radioactive
iodine doesn't get taken in and then
irradiate the tissue next to it but
anyway the idea is that thing that's a
bug when it comes to nuclear meltdowns
is a feature when it comes to treating
cats with a
a cancer a tumorous thyroid
because cats it turns out have two
thyroids
and when one of them is overproducing it
causes the other one to shrink and
basically go dormant right there's a
feedback mechanism in which they both do
their job but when one of them is
overdoing it the other one stops doing
it at all
so that's lucky because what it means
but humans don't have this so you can't
do this thing you can't do this thing
with humans it means that if you give a
cat with this tumorous thyroid
radioactive iodine what happens is the
thyroid that's overproductive picks up
the iodine and then the tissue in that
thyroid gets radioactively killed it's
basically
it is a radiation treatment for cancer
locally targeted where you don't even
have to
have a you know a ray gun that that
points the radiation it uses an
understanding of the physiology of the
animal right so it's just that the
animal takes up the iodine it kills off
the thyroid and at the point the one
that
kills off the broken thyroid at which
point the other one wakes up and does
the job and it presumably does more job
than it would ordinarily because it's
now missing a partner but the point is
it put the cat right back into health so
i think we just had to we had to keep
him in isolation for a week so that he
wouldn't radiate the other cats we i
think we had three cats at the time it's
not even that the cat would radiate oh
it was his
instruments yes you have to be very
careful uh to to take care of the litter
box in a way that is yes sensitive now
probably it's
a little
more caution is actually necessary um
but
i thought it was one that was amazing it
was one of the most beautiful things
it wasn't
we were graduate students oh my god
but it was what what a beautiful
leveraging of a bizarre
confluence of things right you have
radioactive iodine the cat has this
unique situation of these paired
thyroids that
it was just it was it was amazing how
yeah perfectly it took a cat that looked
like he was
on the
fast route out of the world and restored
him to perfect health yeah um
that's beautiful that's excellent and i
think i i think with regard to processes
actually um medicine has done a number
of of things and then of course
it's
it's it's fixed some things then
overstepped and destroyed and i'm
actually thinking about what is there's
a
history of like hernia repair
involves sewing up tissue and then at
some point someone invents this mesh
and then it turns out the mesh is
terrible yeah but for many decades and
maybe even still most people who do
hernia repairs use this mesh for like
inguinal and guided hernias right they
meshed up the whole industry um but i
don't remember like what so i think
maybe you get even like cardiovascular
neurological tissue and meshing with the
mesh and but then your body can react i
don't remember exactly what the problem
with the mesh is but it's it's bad yeah
it is bad yeah and it has caused
so
i think ralph nader wrote a piece years
ago in which he was like uh don't do
that mesh thing go to canada there's a
place
they don't do mesh by the time you
pay for your trip and everything it's as
cheap as getting the mesh repair in you
know even including the hospital stay in
the special
special hospital in canada but anyway
yeah look it's a terrible idea to take
a synthetic mesh and embed it in tissue
because of course that's going to
trigger your immune system it's going to
trigger systems
for isolating things that have become
embedded
right it interfaces with your biology
and the point is this is one of these
cases where
you need the precautionary principle to
tell you that is really unlikely to be a
good idea in the end
yes yes
yeah
um wow that was when did we start zach
uh you've been going for exactly an hour
exactly an hour okay well let me try to
get through a couple more questions here
um how have you regarded and or have
come to regard our second amendment
right especially in the context of
degeneration into a totalitarian state
yes well i i wrote a piece about this
and my argument at the time
this was an unheard spell unh erd which
is a british publication that that we
quite like
anyway my argument was that
it's very common for
liberals to question the rationale
of the second amendment
because conservatives will often say
that its purpose is
fending off governmental tyranny and
people i think sam harris has made this
point in fact i know he has in an
otherwise very excellent essay he wrote
called something like the riddle of the
gun
this is from way back many years ago uh
but anyway he questioned sam questions
this logic and he says well you know
what exactly do you think you're going
to do with the weapons that you can buy
against the us army for example and the
answer is different so i made the
argument in my piece which was not
responsive to sam but it was responsive
to this question
was
that there's a difference between
the threat that coyotes
uh
coyotes the dogs yeah coyotes create for
house cats versus foxes and it's not
that either a fox or a coyote couldn't
kill a cat they can
but coyotes can do it with
relatively little damage in reverse a
fox even though it could kill a cat
would suffer in so doing and so they
generally don't and so
i think the point is we've got lots of
examples in which an out-gunned military
force succeeded because either it had
more at stake or it was willing to
engage
in tactics that simply drove out you
know
an invading army etc and
i do think that
um and i am not saying that i don't
think we pay a terrible cost for the
second amendment i think the evidence is
mixed but that it's pretty clear that at
least part of the explanation for the
terrible mass shootings and things has
to do with the ubiquity of guns and we
probably ought to deal with them very
differently
i do think it's amazing
that it is
harder
by a lot
to get a motorcycle license in oregon
than it is to pass a background check
and buy a gun
um a lot harder and i speak from
experience i do i i think this is this
is absurd and i do think that part of
the answer is to recognize
that the
second amendment rights are vital but
that we don't treat them
in the right way and that basically
those who are for responsible gun
ownership
are
fighting an endless battle over the
people who are obviously wildly
irresponsible
which is not a totally curable problem
but it's a largely curable problem if we
were to treat them differently so anyway
yes i do think that there is a strong
argument to be made that
uh tyranny of the kind that we saw in
um
australia and canada in the last year
played out differently in the u.s
because of the level of
gun ownership and that we ought to think
carefully about what that means
and
i think we ought to recognize that one
of the implications if that's true is
that if you go through a long period in
which tyranny is not an evident threat
and you begin to get the idea that it's
not that your constitution is so good
that tyranny will never be an issue for
you again
it's very tempting to get rid of your
guns especially if uh
um mentally unstable people keep
unleashing them on
an innocent public yeah
but the problem is
at the point you need those guns because
the real benefit of having them is very
rare but very important and it comes in
the form of fending off tyranny you may
not have them which may be what happened
to australia yes
good um
there are several excellent questions
here and i'm only going to get to two
more because we've been at it for a
while i apologize to those whom we don't
get to
penultimate question
regarding college and rights of passage
what if we encourage one year of staunch
individualism from our high school
graduating youth
now individualism is capitalized as if
that's a that's a
set thing but i'm going to assume that
that's it's not meant that way um
i what are you smoking about i'm trying
to envision
how this would work
right so i mean this
my question would be what what does that
mean right what does that look like
um i do think that one way you could
imagine it to look like unless unless
there's something called like staunch
individualism that we're just not aware
of um
one way it could look like is the gap
year that many people
do take sometimes it's just it's
misspent it's it's not interesting
one of my one of my best students at
evergreen actually uh wrote a book on
the virtues of gap year with one or both
of his parents after he had taken one
which was several years before i met him
as my student
and he he did this is adam um hey claire
he did extraordinary stuff on his gap
year
met you know
learned skills including spanish and met
people and
who came to be like family whom he
continued to know you know many many
many years down down the road and it was
far more
uh maturing
than a freshman year of college would
have been which he also then had right
so i think there are a lot of ways to
to
to do to encourage
something that looks like staunch
individualism
that uh can be effective but also there
will be a tendency to fall into sort of
old habits if you're in the same space
so that's why i think i think gap years
for instance are most effective when
they're someplace else some place not
the same place you spent high school
yes i'm actually on something of a gap
century
are you
phds yes it will take at least 100 years
before getting a second one no wait
before you go on though um
i do think we have a new problem here
right i think gap years are great in
principle i don't think
given the
thing that we allowed to happen to
college yeah now gap year assumes that
college is is a worthy and high school
happens and that a gap between them you
know yes a gap between them at least
will not have the toxin that was in both
the high school you came from and the
college you're going to yeah yeah but i
don't think we've armed people with the
tools to know what to do with that time
and my guess is if you actually did say
all right you're going to take time off
that almost no matter where you sent
people
they would end up spending that time on
the internet
right it would not be productive and so
i do think you need something
that breaks
that pattern
that you will have to have armed people
in advance of the gap year with some
tools so that they can
set some kind of goal and try to
accomplish it whether that's picking up
a skill or seeing something or other
getting somewhere climbing or whatever i
don't know but
that absent it will be rudderless
in a way that it wouldn't have been 20
years ago even
by virtue of
further decay of the system and the
elaboration of the
uh
the nuisance that is the internet that
will attract them away from useful
things right now and i think
unfortunately negative connotation word
is writerless positive connotation word
could be considered serendipity
but this is a different thing this is a
actually being dragged into the
addictive force that is social media and
or other aspects of the internet so
that's not it's not renderless it's
actually you know it's a it's a bad
attractor
to a different to a different place and
there are still places on the earth
where you can't get to the internet
and they are worth being in
uh and
you once you have spent some time in
them maybe you have the
power of will
to impose a regular sabbath on yourself
you know internet sabbath
but it's tough and especially at the
point that you are talking about fresh
out of high school how do you encourage
how do you encourage real independence
of thought
it's tough what i have it okay i figured
it out i know i don't know how to make
it happen
and i don't know what the name for it
would be
but
they have to spend a year amish
i mean am i wrong yes because the amish
won't have them i know
and there's too many of them too there's
not enough amish even no i know i know
but but in principle because the modern
the amish the
amish are not susceptible to but it's a
great money-making opportunity you know
they're happy to make money but it's
they're not gonna do it because of that
no
no
still though i mean i know i put it in a
way that's absurd
but it is the right thing right they
have to i mean i don't i don't see how
that's any more operationalized
than staunch individualism um it's a
different it's not staunch individualism
it's a different thing but i don't see i
i continue not to see
because
in light of a system an educational
system that completely fails to educate
how
it does not create
mental independence it does not create
the capacity to accomplish things to
build it does not
does not produce a
prototyping mindset it does not do any
of those things
that that in effect the only thing that
is likely to tell somebody who's been a
victim of that system where they
actually are
is
isolation from all of the crutches that
allow them to get by and feel capable
right
and so in some sense i am being serious
that well so you know another way i
think to frame what you just said is
find a way to actually enforce
beginner's mind because you know the
crutches that make you feel capable but
and hidden in that thing that you said
is
you aren't actually capable they just
make you feel capable
get rid of the things that make you feel
capable
so that you can actually discover and
develop capability
right and what a tragedy that even as
much as that would be a huge upgrade for
most people
that it would be poorly leveraged in
light of the fact that what we
effectively do when we send kids to
school is waste their time
right where they could be developing the
ability to make use of such a period
most of what that period would do is
reveal to them how badly we
betrayed them by failing to educate them
when they were most amenable to it
indeed
one last question
is there more physical and cognitive
variability among men than women
probably yes in some regards absolutely
yes
there is some evidence for instance that
um iq take whatever issues you have with
iq as as you will but um if you're
talking about iq for both men and women
um the average is the same for men and
women but the variance
is much higher among men there are more
um genius and bozo men there are than
there are either switch those hands it
will feel less personal
i was
it was just right it's high i know okay
yeah um
definitely was not personal um
so yeah and and
then there's but there's a lot of stuff
actually that um
women do better than men and men do
better than women and so it's not that
there's greater variability it's just
it's domains so sort of the forest for
the trees argument there's a good
uh paper that i've talked about in some
piece that i've written and maybe on air
in which
across a number of domains
uh women seem to be better at at uh
details and men at gist and so you know
seeing the forest and the trees women
are better at um
men may be better at root finding but
they need the women to find the keys for
them in the first place
so i have summarized the results of this
paper
and
and it's not across all demands and of
course it's overlapping distributions
all the usual caveats um so you know not
not across everything what is is the
greater male variability hypothesis
going to apply and that's what you are
alluding to here but yes in many cases
with regard to physical stuff i don't
know well um
in one there's one simple way yeah i can
think of one simple way but what do you
what are you thinking of that um in
terms of the most capable men physically
are outside the domain that women reach
but that's not that's not responsive
you know is is the range different or is
the range bigger yeah because the range
is bigger inherent i'm not arguing that
this is important i'm arguing that it's
trivial but basic point is yes there
will be men as
totally incapable
who are effectively zero capable right
so you're saying it may be it may be
that it's that
whatever physical feature we're talking
about that might otherwise follow a
normal distribution
might not for men you might just have
greater capacity over here and it might
just fall off well both men and women
will have individuals at
no case of course that's so the point is
if men at their most capable are
physically more capable than the point
is yeah it's by definition a bigger
range
right not interesting
um but it's by definition a bigger range
um
but but on the so the non-trivial
example
uh
way in which men will have greater
physical variability than women that i
was thinking of that uh yeah um
was that childbirth constrains um
shape of a skeleton
and therefore attending soft tissue and
cardiovascular neurological stuff
in a way that men's bodies are you know
male and female bodies are both
constrained by all of the forces of
natural selection onto which women have
the additional constraints of childbirth
which is which is likely to make uh
women's bodies more of a type
i think maybe i'm not positive about
that well i mean there are there are two
distortions right you've got ecological
optimum you've got a distortion for
childbirth that applies to females and
you've got a distortion for
uh
interest sex competition
for males both of which push you away
from the ecological optimum
so and i think
that will have that will have some
implication not obvious which direction
it goes but i think
the point is it pushes males it is the
thing that makes males uh more
physically capable at the extreme
but i wanted to go back to the the
cognitive one because i think there's
something
always hidden in such questions okay
people make the assumption that when you
say do
you know is there more variance in
um
cognitive capacity in males than females
yes okay
um
they assume that that implies that the
genome
creates that condition
right rather than the developmental
environment and i'm not telling you
which it is or that it isn't both
but what i am telling you is that one
possibility
is that
males are
rewarded for certain stuff that causes
them to either become bozos as you put
it or geniuses more often
and that were you to alter the culture
that you that there's nothing about
female brains that won't do that it's
more about whether or not it is um
there is a rewarding path built for it
and so just in the same way that you
know a hundred years ago you wouldn't
have found that many women interested in
you know
uh
competing athletically as their primary
thing in the world and the world changed
and it became accepting of it first and
then it became rewarding of it and that
didn't
totally erase
male athletic superiority in the extreme
but the point is wow what women turned
out to be capable of you wouldn't
necessarily predict
from 100 or 200 years back and
what we don't i don't think we know
how much the
genome
reading this is a male individual versus
this is a female individual creates
biases that would be difficult or
impossible to overcome
developmentally
and to which extent it's just simply
that yes it did make sense in a prior
world
for women who are lower variance in
terms of reproductive
potential
to be lower variance in these other
regards too and that to the extent that
we've changed the rules of the game we
may discover all kinds of things that
seem genetically based just simply
weren't yep
very good
uh i think i think we're there i think
we may be i think we're there we will be
back again next week same time same
place and after that it's going to be
much more variable much more variable
you think zach is going to give us our
end screen i think he is i suspect he
will yeah and has i think i think i
think he has and will
um
so thank you for joining us as always uh
and
do
we we are we're very curious
about the flatlining of the subscriber
count on both of our channels this
channel well all four i guess um youtube
and odyssey main channels and youtube
and odyssey darkhorse podcast clips
channels um exactly as we are seeing
greater and greater numbers in all of
the other
uh domains so it seems it seems
suspicious and uh we do encourage you to
subscribe if you uh if you feel like
doing so especially if you did before
and did not unsubscribe yourself
knowingly and have been somehow
unsubscribed reese's re-subscribe to our
channels
yeah
is there something right there nope i
just think it's a good policy okay
covers how you ended up unsubscribed
yeah
um all right
lots of other stuff to say but we'll
save it for next week all right about
that
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you